Mr President nuclear missiles will
strike our country in 14 minutes I know
it's your first day in office I'm going
to walk you through it but you're the
only one who can authorize our nuclear
retaliation in response and you've only
got a few minutes to make a decision as
you know tensions have escalated rapidly
in the past few days today's joint
Allied aerial defense exercise began
just minutes before we detected the
launch a simple misunderstanding maybe
we assume the sudden attack is meant to
neutralize as many of our nuclear forces
as possible but that doesn't matter now
missiles are in the air and we can't
shoot all of them down why because
intercontinental ballistic missiles are
basically rockets launched into space
before re-entering the atmosphere over
their target and releasing many
different Warheads higher and faster
than anything you can send after them we
need to get you to the bunker
[Music]
here's what we know four minutes ago our
new infrared monitoring satellites
detected 112 bursts consistent with ICBM
launches from the enemy's inner
territories for some reason only 20 of
their 80 underground nuclear silos seem
to have fired so we suspect most of them
were transporter erector launchers you
know trucks with big missiles on them
it's unclear why they didn't use all
their silos they might just not work
after more than 30 years or they might
be keeping them in reserve the fog of
war is keeping many things unclear
Aerospace command thinks the icbms are
targeting our nuclear command centers
silos and major air force and navy bases
ending this war before we have a chance
to act the enemy's strategic Doctrine
prioritizes military targets and our
nuclear weapon systems but their
secondary targets are our industry and
infrastructure all refineries power
stations and deep water ports all
located near or in major population
centers
we won't know the exact casualty count
for a few weeks deaths from the blast
and burns may be a few million today
it's morning Russia and there's not much
to be done for people stuck in traffic
people in major Metro areas can't really
evacuate but emergency broadcasts are
being sent out to shelter in place and
away from Windows radiation exposure for
intact population centers is highly
dependent on the weather over the next
week we might be looking at dozens of
millions of deaths by the end of the
month for the next few minutes we can
still respond but you need to decide
we've got 1500 Warheads across our silos
bombers and submarines the 400 in silos
need to be launched now before they get
taken out 46 nuclear-capable bombers on
high alert can be ready to take off in
two minutes though we need to transmit
the order right away to get them out of
the blast radius if you want to consider
using them of our 40 nuclear submarines
five are presently at Sea while they're
submerged they're undetectable so that's
our backup for a nuclear retaliation if
we lose our silos and bombers we could
try to use them to bomb out their
remaining Silo field before they can
launch them the sooner you commit to it
the better the chance we have of
preventing a further exchange after our
retaliation
updates we have radar confirmation that
the enemy icbms have completed their
burn and deployed their Warheads our
best guess is that each missile will
deploy at least six re-entry Vehicles
about 600 in total which is the part
that carries a warhead back into the
atmosphere during its terminal descent
onto the Target and with many more
decoys on top of that inflatable
balloons meant to waste any
anti-missiles we are now tracking nearly
4 000 potential targets our
anti-ballistic missiles have been
launched and will begin their Intercept
in another minute we'll do our best to
protect the capital although there
really is no defense
wait confirming a partial radar blackout
our systems seem to be glitchy
it must have anticipated with launch our
interceptors and predetonated a few
Warheads at high altitude that ionizes
the atmosphere and creates radar
interference Aaron's receptors should
still operate okay they've had a 55
success rate in tests but never this
many decoys or with radar interference
this intense we might shoot down 50
objects but there's no guarantee their
Warheads it looks like most bombs are
going to get through
this is our last chance to
counter-attack we're out of time our
solar launch sequence takes five minutes
we have to transmit and confirm a launch
order and the missile needs time to
clear the blast radius of the incoming
bomb
this is a lot to take in but the war
plan is made you just need to enter the
launch authorization codes and push this
button to transmit them you can't do
anything else to save more of our people
if you don't launch now then this war
will be over before it even begins you
understand this is our one chance right
the effect
enemy civilian casualties are hard to
estimate but should be similar to ours a
few million right away perhaps a few
tens of Million by the end of the month
the total Fallout from their attacks and
ours might trigger a nuclear winter
potentially killing billions around the
world but that might happen even if we
don't retaliate I'm sure you have
questions but you have to give orders
without expecting answers right now with
an attack of this scale there's no
guarantee Communications or assets will
be intact in a few minutes we're out of
time we need a decision sir
can we launch
nuclear Wars aren't regular Wars they
only last minutes and in times of Crisis
small conflicts can rapidly spiral out
of control anything from small
communication lags to sensor errors to
just uncertainty in the fog of War mean
that no leader will ever have a complete
idea of what's Happening as a crisis
unfolds when tensions are high accidents
or misunderstandings can steerly does
even those with good intentions to
launch a nuclear attack
confused them with incomplete
information a single person yes it's
really just one single person who
decides can literally make civilization
ending decisions killing hundreds of
millions of people in the time it takes
to watch a YouTube video
this story is fiction but the world came
very close to this several times in 1995
Russian radar detected a submarine
launch missile and their nuclear forces
went on full alert except it was
actually a scientific rocket to study
auroras in 1979 U.S computers reported a
full-scale Soviet attack with only
minutes to respond except it was a
training tape being incorrectly loaded
into a computer in 1983 the Soviet
satellite alert system showed five icbms
launched from the US but it was a false
alarm caused by sunlight to reflected on
clouds during the Cuban Missile Crisis a
Soviet submarine with no contact to
Moscow for several days concluded that
nuclear war had begun and decided to
launch a nuclear torpedo luckily the
authorization of three officers was
required one of them Vasily ashipov
opposed it but what if he hadn't any
Safeguard can fail no matter how
carefully designed it might be
and decisions are being made right now
to build new weapons and missile systems
that commit the world to another Century
of nuclear stalemate complicated further
by China's emergence as a new nuclear
superpower
plea accepting that the existence of
nuclear weapons is inevitable might mean
their use is inevitable
but the world doesn't have to be this
way even incremental stabs taking apart
one bomb at a time will eventually
result in a world with none
during the Cold War the world had over
70 000 nuclear weapons through arms
reduction traces that number is now
about 12 500. progress is not guaranteed
but it's also not impossible
governments and militaries are not
separate from their Nations they're part
of them just like you you have the power
to make demands of your leaders and
often this begins with just being aware
of an issue if you want to learn more
we've compiled a number of resources for
you in the video description and our
sources
this video was supported by open
philanthropy did you know that there are
countless more korzkazar videos that we
upload on Tick Tock YouTube shorts and
Instagram reels bite-sized information
animated facts and inspiring thought
experiments after all you also need
videos you can watch quickly in a
bathroom break our longer more in-depth
videos are Happening Here on YouTube
short form is a completely different
challenge that we're trying to do as
well as possible check them out if
you're curious and if you want to
discuss and share your thoughts about
science with other like-minded people
why don't you check out our Discord
Community with over 80 000 burbs we have
channels where you can chat about stem
topics participate in events and the
academic question of the week and we
have the best emotes after all we want
to spark your curiosity but it's always
more fun to be curious together see you
over there
thank you
[Music]